[Applause]  having career highs averaging 22  shooting over  53 fourth team foul on milwaukee  [Applause]  this  to be time story for the rest of his  life  james hard with 13 points in this fourth  quarter  nice pass could not connect  but the artist does and  the bucks lead by two following the shot  rocker usually that block shot is gonna  be your rebound  great finish  harris with the catch  [Applause]  45 seconds left in  [Applause]  off of the offensive rebound three and  eight ten  seconds to go in this fourth quarter how  do they look he didn't bat he does  committed to his three point three fires  in and out and the nets for the victory  and a dramatic  um  mvp to be somewhere inside where he has  a chance to